power sinker baller adrian hauser his
first two starts couldn't go any better
one-on-one record a .75 earned run
average kepler 4 for 20 on this road
trip with a couple homers and five
knocked in
as kepler slices one caught by urias i'd
rather sogar to beg your pardon so guard
over on the ship makes the play for the
out and nice play that ball was slicing
away from him as he went up the middle
little bouncer over to third sogar fires
to first and a one two three inning for
adrian hauser it'll be the right hand to
randy dobneck making his fourth start
and appearance this year
had a great one his last time out
four no record in night games two are on
and nobody out here in the opening
inning christian yelling to hit number
four in yesterday's win
there's the ground ball
just one out
both runners move up one way
garcia and here's the pitch of swinging
a fly ball into center field deep byron
going back still going and makes the
catch on the warning track so dobneck
escapes a first inning jam the twins
have some base runners here two on two
out and let's see if byron buxton can
keep that hot bat rolling here
there's a swing and a miss he struck him
out with that power sinker
first strikeout for hauser the twin
strand a pair
gamma 222 with a couple of home runs and
seven driven in from the wind up and the
one two strike three call the backdoor
curveball
and gamble strikes out looking one out
second strikeout for dobneck here's
arcia now with a runner at first and two
outs three and two the count runner goes
garcia turns on one back on it is
rosario and rosario can't make the play
urias will score easily
arcia into second base with an rbi
double
well it looked like rosario was there
but he just whipped it on the lead
in the air long run for yelich
slicing into foul grounds oh what a play
by yelich
the ball popped out and the umpire is
going to say no catch he's not going to
give him the out
right there that's an out i mean that's
got to be colder now of course he kind
of loses it right there maybe not
okay here we go
you can't see
so now the bases are loaded for eddie
rosario just like that rosario with the
bases loaded this season is one for four
he's had the most at bats with the bases
loaded of any twins in great position to
at least tie the game and rosario
to right field and deep and
go on a grand slam teeing off on the
first pitch eddie rosario puts the twins
in front 4-1 well that's how you regain
the momentum right there eddie
sitting on a fastball quite honestly
he's one of those dangerous guys with
bases loaded
[Applause]
this one grounded to the right side
urias has it spins fires to first scoop
by smoke yes
nice play luis urias from shadow right
yeah nice play on both ends right there
is able to spin around and throw to
first and then a good pick by
smoke nelson cruz with a runner at first
there goes the runner
garba is throwing a second the tag in
time
with a quick tag what a release by
norway i didn't think they had a chance
to get polacco at second base beautiful
all the way around the quick hands of
arius
uh called strike three right on the edge
hauser
strikes out nelson cruz can't do any
better than that i mean at the knees on
the corner
five of the last six outs have been on
ground balls and most of them not hit
with any authority at all
and shaving the outside edge with a
breaking ball two down little paint job
right there back door slider right on
the bottom quadrant
to the right side another ground ball
out and another really good inning for
randy donna
freddie peralta will get the ball for
craig council as we start playing the
sixth inning it'll be adrianzano
he got him
fastball freddy with a fastball for a
strikeout can't hit that pitch up there
for all to contain speeds with that
slider
[Applause]
yeah he's got another one a strikeout to
end it that's a good pitch
back-to-back case here in the eighth
inning
good battle here between these two
competing 3-2 pitch and a slow curve in
there for a strike nicely done freddie
peralta
kesten hera d-h-ing tonight coming off
an outstanding rookie year
hira that is deep into left center got
good wood on it and it is going to fly
out of here
casting hira goes deep back-to-back
games for hira and it's 4-2 now
mark matthias is the pinch fighter now
trying to keep it alive here with two
outs
got him up and away with a fastball
rogers finally wins the battle and so
much for the losing streak twins take
game one final four two